[Music]
let's go to becky in each town what's up
becky
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call of course gustros what's up yes
hey well i was just calling um i'm
trying to figure out how i can get my
son to respect me
as well as control his outburst that he
has respect my authority
so tell me what's going on
well um so me and his dad are divorced
okay um so i know that takes a toll um
his dad was very much verbally and
emotionally abusive okay towards me in
front of him okay um at the time we
lived together
my son would step up in front of me
which was shocking because he was you
know little and he would be like you
can't talk to mom like that and then now
i find him now that we're separated he
talks to me similar to the way his dad
used to talk to me that's right
that's right
um
you said i know it takes a toll
i want you to think of this as every
single thing he knows burned to the
ground
okay this isn't taking a toll
this is caustic
okay this is the insides of your little
boy or on the outside now it's that big
of a trauma okay
and here's a devastating thing about
what you just described abusive
relationships is especially little kids
but it stays with us until we're adults
is he knows
that part of you
is part of him
and that part of dad is part of him
and so if he identifies dad as bad or
wrong or evil that means part of him is
bad or wrong or evil
and psychologically speaking it's easier
and makes more sense especially in in a
child or a traumatized adult
to identify and to begin to reproduce
the same behaviors
than it is to distance yourself and say
that's evil and wrong and that means a
part of me is dark and i gotta do some
healing inside you see what i'm saying
it's very hard for especially for an
eight-year-old so yeah the easy way to
say it is he's got a picture of how to
treat women
he's got a picture and i'm gonna
follow that picture
until somebody do it to every woman no
because your husband probably didn't do
that to every woman it's not a gender
thing it's a you thing
okay
it's a home thing it's the way
you treat you
because he got a pretty pretty clear
model of that
uh here's a hard ques can i ask you a
couple of hard questions sure go ahead
okay not being mean i just want to get a
full picture
are you
respectable
yeah
tell me about that
look at you you're like yeah
i mean i feel like i'm a good person and
i stick true to my morals and my values
i feel like okay that's one piece
and respectable it has a a moral and a
character thing to it okay
let's pull that apart a little bit and
here's what i mean by respectable do you
have real firm boundaries
are you good with schedules and this is
when bedtime is and you will not speak
to me this way and if you've chosen to
talk to me this way then you're choosing
to leave the room right are there some
consequences too and that's what i mean
by respectable think of respectable as
i'm anchored into steel into concrete
right
are you trying okay there so
here's that little does he live with you
full time
uh yeah he does his dad every other
weekend so right now unfortunately he's
with his dad the whole month so i know i
have a lot of work to do when he comes
back
yeah says he gonna stay with he lives
with you
he lives with me okay yeah and we just
moved out of so he had a whole new
living situation now too so it's been a
lot yeah it's a lot
um
yeah because he went from we lived with
dad and then we moved in with my parents
because i had to leave the you know that
household and you know i left and took
him with me and then separated him from
his siblings
that he has with because his dad has
other kids and then now we've moved to
our own home buyers you know our own
home
so his world is doesn't exist upside
down for the last like two years yeah
okay here's where we're gonna start okay
there's gonna be and this is gonna be a
you're playing a 20-year game now you're
not playing a week-by-week game anymore
okay okay being a 20-year game
that means you're going to have hell on
earth for
for
weeks and sometimes months on end okay
don't fight that know that it's coming
because you got a little boy that thinks
he did
something that sent dad away forever
he thinks he did something that took
brothers and sisters away
he thinks if i'd just done something a
little bit different my dad wouldn't
have been so mean to mom
wait a minute
dad was mean to mom probably was mom's
fault right so he's gonna have to be
processed in his eight-year-old little
brain
right so that's where we're gonna start
we're playing a long game here here's
number two
every son knows not everyone but most
sons know their moms love them
i want you to work really hard to let
your son know that you like him
okay okay and that's hard
especially when he reminds you of your
husband when he talks to you in ways at
your husband so you're gonna have a lot
of deprogramming to do after a month
right
when he complains about things and you
know he's kind of right you're like i
had lots of brothers and sisters and
friends and we did a bunch of stuff and
you make me do homework you're the worst
i can see that
i mean that makes sense to me
um
he had to lose everything just so you
could be safe like that math doesn't
work in an eight-year-old's head
okay
and he's gonna need you to be patient
and to love him obviously but to like
him and here's how we like our kids we
set up situations where we can
be successful
so we're going to have boundaries we're
going to firm firm boundaries we're
going to have strong anchor points and
we're going to have some silly moments
we're going to be unreasonable sometimes
hey you just want to have ice cream for
dinner yep right we're gonna do silly
things
uh i'm gonna come pick you up randomly
once every few months from school and
we're gonna go to the arcade just blow
and go to the movie
and i'm going to do this because i like
you
i value spending time with you
you aren't the reason
i left dad
he was right and this is a lifelong
journey he's gonna have to go under uh
undergo um
and then here's a couple other things
he's gonna need some real direct
counseling okay he's in play therapy
good good good good um my guess is he's
gonna have rage that would
okay make people's teeth fall out okay
um
they're gonna throw all kind of
diagnostic labels at you and all this
this is they said these adhd of course
they will and it's gonna move to
oppositional defiant disorder in the
next year or two right you'll get all
these diagnose labels here's the way i
want you to hear those things
it's a little boy's body trying to
um respond to his world exploding
okay
so those all those labels and that your
son's not broken
i know right he's not dysfunctional he
is trying to make sense of something
that it cannot be made sense out of
and he needs a mom who likes him here's
the third thing i want you to do and you
may have heard me talk about this on the
show a lot
when he gets back this summer
i want you to go to michael's or to like
uh what do you call it one of those home
goods stores where you can buy a big
canvas like a three foot by five foot
one a big one
and i want you to do a big painting
project together where you're gonna
paint a thing on it and then
i want you to take him to a real nice
dinner like make him dress up
okay and we're going to talk about who
we are family values and when you're in
this house because he's going to toggle
back and forth between homes
yeah it's going to be impossible for his
little eight-year-old nine-year-old 10
year old brain to toggle that but that's
what the courts do okay
so when he's in your house this is who
we are
and let him talk into that let him
express yeah yeah
and we are in fill in the blank and some
of those things in my house are we talk
to each other with dignity and respect
we're kind to one another even when
we're upset
we're allowed to be angry but we're not
going to be disrespectful in our anger
we pick up after ourselves we laugh a
lot
we fill in the blank right we go on
adventures we say yes we invite people
over these are some of the delony family
values they're gonna be different for
you guys but here's why they're
important
for the next
15 years
they're a touchstone for you what i mean
by that when he has an outburst
and he blows up at you here's what he's
trying to find out are you going to
leave too
is there something i can do that you'll
leave like dad did
and he needs to know absolutely not but
he can make some choices to where he
decides to leave
and he'll take ownership of that real
fast
here's what i mean
let's say he comes in and you say hey
pick up your backpack and he goes i
don't pick up my backpack for stupid
women let's say he says something like
that
you can say get out
get out
what he knows by that
is there is a line with which mom will
weaponize our relationship and kick me
out of her presence
the other way to do that is to sit down
and look him in the eye and say
you've chosen to violate one of our
family values because in this house we
talk to each other with dignity and
respect and you chose to be
disrespectful which means you chose to
leave
my presence
you chose to leave our family table
and i want you here i like you better
than being here alone
and i breaks my heart that you i'm
choosing to have my heart broken that
you chose to leave for 10 minutes please
go do your 10 minutes and choose to come
back in here because i want you here
you see the difference
and he is going to take quick ownership
of i get to choose when i'm in a
relationship with mom and i want to be
with mom because she likes me
he thinks everything's like like my
fault like if he gets in trouble it's my
fault that he's in trouble absolutely
and then he goes into this wall maybe i
should just die or maybe i should kill
myself or he'll throw things or he'll
like hit his head or shrink whatever and
this is a eight-year-old boy who is
trying to make sense of
chaos
right
and he's using every word he knows every
grenade he knows it's um
it's it's the last soldier in a bunker
and everyone around him is gone and he's
gonna throw every grenade he's got
that's all he's got last last ditch
effort he's eight right
and here's what we're teaching him we're
teaching him that he can choose
because right now he's felt completely
powerless to everybody leaving in his
life
and yes he's going to blame you when he
asks dad how come you don't live with us
well because your mom walked out on me
that's how that's what he says that's
how the story right he's eight he's
gonna believe his dad he looks like his
dad he wants to be like his yeah he does
look like his father that's right so he
sees a reflection of himself and he
didn't not like himself so it must be
your fault right so that's what i'm
saying you're playing a 20-year game the
goal isn't to get him to like you
the goal is to get him to understand
that he's likable
right and that means he's gonna say
eight-year-old stuff
also if you threaten suicide you call in
everybody every time on that right you
know that um i don't mess around with
that but when it comes to this is your
fault
um you can say
i'm so sorry that you're hurting it's
not my fault but i respect your right to
be upset
i'm sad that this is the way this is too
let him know that you're a person and
that you didn't you didn't draw this one
up either right
okay and it's gonna be a long game and
he'll say things over the years that
will break your heart you gotta have
people in your life that you can talk to
as well is that fair
um
congratulations i'm proud of you for
looking in the mirror and saying he
deserves more than you deserve more than
to be abused
thank you i know that that is a grenade
that blew up everything in your life too
i'm sorry that happened
um
it's real hard right now and you feel
like you're losing you've lost almost
everything and that you're losing your
son
um i think you did the right thing i'm
proud of you
thank you
um you have a good job you're working i
do yep okay
putting it like money's okay you're
putting it together
yeah i'm i'm fine good good good good um
i'll walk with you as long as until i
get fired this podcast goes away
um but will you call me back if you ever
need anything
sure okay
um i'll walk alongside you the whole way
work real closely with school counselors
work real closely with school at some
point
again this is pie in the sky i'm just
dreaming here
at some point
potentially possibly
you and your ex
are able to
um he's able to not be a child
not talk bad about you
not because he's not mad and not because
he's not pouting or whatever but because
he wants his son to grow up and be whole
and be well
and um
i hear that more and more these days
that people are wise enough and smart
enough and adult enough to understand
that yes our marriage was a wreck we
blew it up it didn't work i cheated i
got mad i was abusive whatever
but i'm gonna
be respectful to you moving forward as
we co-parent our kid because our kid
deserves more
than repeating this nonsense
um that's my hope that maybe in this
situation never gonna happen but i'm
gonna
i'm gonna hold out hope for that
thanks for calling becky and i'll holla
back if you ever need anything